who's
one you wouldn't be comfortable sharing
secrets with if you were to say there's
no way in the world we would do anything
with the following three
who would it be that would be iran iran
iran
[Laughter]
so iran's at the top so you're more
uncomfortable with teaching iran
anything than china i think china is
doing a clinic right now around the
world with people no china is doing a
lot and they
are they worry me and the russians worry
me i'd say i'd say realistically
russia china uh uh iran um
are syria
any of the countries that are clearly
at odds uh uh with us but that's four or
five
uh there are a few that would
work with us even though not all the
time interesting
so before we get into your new book
that's coming out operation dragon
inside the kremlin
secret war on america uh i want to kind
of ask you
maybe a couple other questions here
regarding today's times you know
i've asked this question from multiple
different people
to see what their answer would be uh
being a director of cia 93 to 95
had different issues than we're facing
today
than maybe in the 70s than maybe in the
60s it's different challenges during
different decades
what what what concerns you the most
today
i mean i'm talking is it cyber warfare
is it bionuclear
is it nuclear is it you know bio warfare
is it uh a uh uh
oil war that could take place is it you
know what what is the top concern that
you have with all the different
challenges we're facing today
well it's tough because it's a
combination on the one hand
of intelligence forces or groups i mean
i'm
much more worried about iran than i
am about most any other country and
and but in addition to
naming some names like iran
um i'm uh i'm um
really quite uh concerned
uh about especially specialities
that have been adopted by
russia and china uh which are
are very very troubling because
russia for example has been working very
hard
on cyber particularly artificial
intelligence
and uh uh that that is
a continuing source of uh
confusion and uh difficulty for the
united states because
uh uh the the russians uh
lie cheat and steal about who they are
and uh
that makes it very difficult
what do you do with somebody with a face
mask that's extremely well uh
designed and uh you're sure that
he's a syrian in fact he may not be
he may be opposed to syrians i don't
so there are um
a lot of difficulties
with masking and such uh technology uh
cyber for in all dimensions uh are
is really hard to deal with uh and um
i'd say uh that uh
set of of technologies and that set
of um governments
uh are uh are six eight
ten twelve uh really really troubling uh
combinations of individual
countries and individual uh
texts and and uh
operators so when when you were director
of cia from 93 to 95.
uh obviously russia was probably your
biggest threat would you agree russia
would be number one on the list 93-95 as
a nation
i think probably so we
we were not as uh worried about russia
then as i think we uh should have been
um and uh we uh
worked to some extent
on the
steps russia could could take
in masking themselves
and they did that a lot
uh they uh the temp potemkin
village uh history uh the
disguise for a whole village uh by
count potemkin who is sort of catherine
the great's uh
male friend uh was uh
one of the things the the russians did
and
it did going back to the 17th century
um they they're good at deception and uh
we we were always needing to
penetrate that was not easy during that
time
was china at all even a thought uh you
know was it even something where you
woke up and
you know hey we have to be careful what
china is going to be doing next
obviously russia was up there iran was
up there was china still in the top
three at the time or no
i don't know that it was in the top
three
but it was very close it was it was in
the top
one or two or three uh it can't
you can't really tell but uh they were
a problem but not as serious a problem i
think they thought as say
russia was now it may be different the
uh ranking of the uh
chinese and russians and iranians uh
syrians uh is is
hard to parse but all four or five of
those
countries are worrisome so if you like
this sort of short clip from an
interview i did click over here to watch
the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel take care
everybody bye
[Music]